hello Chicago Chicago how you doing we
lost two MBA family members who meant so
much to the league to our fans and also
to communities all over the country
David Stern was one of the greatest
commissioners that any league has ever
seen actually at the all-star game in
Orlando when I had just announced HIV
David Stern allowed me to play in the
game and he actually saved my life and
he also saved millions of people's lives
who were living with HIV around the
world
[Applause]
he allow players like myself and all
these young players to be in households
all over the world thank God we have his
vision was to have the NBA be a global
game and now look how many international
players we have playing in the NBA today
is made the game better because of that
and then number eight and number
twenty-four Kobe Bryant
I'm gonna say that one more time because
that that cheer should be a little bit
louder Kobe Bryant
there you go
we'll never see another basketball
player quite like Kobe scoring 81 points
in one game scoring 60 points in his
last game and then winning five NBA
championships but what I'm really proud
about when we think about Kobe Bryant
there's millions of people in Los
Angeles who don't have a home Kobe was
fighting to get them homes and shelter
every single day he was passionate about
that he was also passionate about being
a great father husband filmmaker young
man won an Oscar so we all are hurting
this is a tough time for the whole NBA
family and if I can get you all the
rides right quick
[Music]
[Applause]
there you go all I want you to do just
for both David and Kobe just hold hands
for one second we need to really embrace
each other at this time this tough time
come together love each other Co we
would have wanted that that's very
important and if we can just have it
quiet for eight seconds
god bless you now
[Applause]
and how ironic is is that Kobe has
worked out with a lot of these guys and
or giving them great advice he was
always there for all of us in one way or
another so to pay tribute to Kobe
Chicago's own Jennifer Hudson